[Musica]
allora io non lo posso nascondermi ha
presentato come tale quindi lo sapete
sono commercialista commercialista e con
brutto soggetto da cui recate quando
dovete far cosa fare quella cosa certa
certa altrettanto come la morte esatto
pagare le tasse
e in quel momento lì di vento proprio
ancor più brutto e cattivo che in
qualsiasi altro momento nell'anno che
d'estate quando sono chiuso lì sul nel
mio studio dietro la scrivania che sudo
perché l'aria condizionata non me l'ha
permesso perché devo anche soffrire
mentre sono lì che calcolo le tasse
dell'imposta perché faccio qualcosa di
così tremendo e mi auto infliggono una
punizione perché se fosse per me le
tasse non le paga reste è proprio in
quel periodo lì nel lontano 2013 si
presenta un cliente amico che mi diceva
ti ricordi che io qualche anno fa sono
stato a londra perché mio padre mi ha
spedito li sapete classico figli papa
con la tendina che funziona bene
giustamente il padre saggio di dice
sentiti dopo 500 euro prendi parti
biglietto per londra et arrangi da solo
dopo un mese vuole tornare a casa e
padri dice non mi spiace ciccio mio
letto che rimani lì perché deve imparare
la lingua da imparare a vivere da
imparare a stare al mondo e imparare
stare al mondo per lui è voluto anche
dire affrontare una sfida nuova cioè
rilanciarsi con dei lavoretti i lavori
picco di piccolo cabotaggio fino puoi
diventare barista comincia a guadagnare
qualche soldino in più potersi pagare un
affitto in un appartamentino in
condivisione nel quale però cioè ci
passava interamente il suo tempo libero
perché i soldi per uscire e spese non
aveva cosa ha fatto col suo bel computer
portatile ha scoperto lui blow ceni
bitcoin per me e ha incominciato a fare
mining cos'è il mining il mining non è
nient'altro che il frutto dell'attività
dei soggetti che partecipano alla rete
bitcoin come nodi che si prendono la
briga di verificare tutte le transazioni
che vengono proposti al protocollo e
insieme a questo risolvono un problema
posto alla base di ogni blocco al fine
di validare tutte le transazioni che
devono essere inserite
quindi le verificano risolvono il
problema è chi prima risolve il problema
si guadagna il diritto di scrivere a
nuova pagina e blocco per far questo ti
prendi una remunerazione sotto forma
degli stessi bitcoin che sono l'oggetto
delle transazioni iscritte in quel
blocco bene lui arriva da medici guarda
io mentre orino sapevo cosa altro fare
ce vò il mio computer per fortuna rubava
un collegamento a 1 un pochettino più
ricco dei miei coinquilini e col tramite
mio collegamento internet mi sono messo
a minare adesso un tosto di bitcoin che
guarda valgono dei soldi io li vorrei
vendere innanzitutto il casco dalla sede
dico scusa mi aspetto ma tempesti
bitcoin perché dovrei pagare te per
ma c'è qualcuno che ti ripaga sti
maledetti bitcoin ma no ma sono delle
monete e sud spetta ascolta io prendo i
miei cinque anni di università di
straccio butto via macroeconomia
economia politica ci hanno spiegato che
la moneta tu non la cre la moneta tuo
privato la moneta la crea lo stato
quindi non prendermi in giro che cosa
che cosa vuoi vendere perché a seconda
dell'oggetto che tu andrai a vendere io
potrò dirti se o quale tipo di
tassazione scorretta o addirittura cioè
quello che stai facendo tu è a tutti gli
effetti un'attività d'impresa
un'attività canale cioè identificarmi
l'oggetto ma non lo guarda è una valuta
una valuta elettronica calma e di io
dovuto iniziare una nuova sfida
concettuale questo mio amico a parte
queste poche informazioni
altro nome ha detto cioè a divertita
provato a spiegarmi tutto il processo di
creazione di validazione dei blocchi è
ma allora era assolutamente arabo
oggi non è che se è molto meglio su
comunque sempre commercialista sono
sempre quel brutto soggetto che bravo a
fare gli f24 ed a dire sto paga queste
sono le tasse che deve lo stato però
qualcosina in più ci ho capito ma la
sfida concettuale che mi è stata posta
in quel momento è stato capire cosa
forse la natura di quel tipo di
operazione che lui aveva eseguito e quel
quella cosa che avevo ottenuto che lui
mi chiamava moneta moneta elettronica
che qualcuno era disposto a pagargli
quindi a remunerare gli ora se si
ottiene una remunerazione in cambio di
un lavoro
tendenzialmente
vuol dire che si è formata una forma di
reddito in italia le categorie
reddituali si applicano per due
caratteristiche fondamentali soggettive
cioè che il tipo di soggetto che pone in
essere con l'attività persona fisica o
persona giuridica soggetta in attività
di impresa o soggetto che svolge un
lavoro dipendente e assimilato e dal
punto di vista oggettivo stiamo parlando
di beni
stiamo parlando di servizi stiamo
parlando di moneta moneta no io li su
moneta ho vacillato un attimino perché
ha detto se io mi vado a prendere io
studio è studio non sembra ma ogni tanto
studio
se vado a prendermi i miei testo unico
sulle imposte e il testo unico iva e
cerco sotto la voce reddito da conio di
monete signora non trovo una forma di
tassazione perché non c'è una forma di
tassazione perché solitamente chi è che
emette boneta che conia moneta la banca
centrale e la banca centrale lo fa non
come produzione di reddito ma per
regolare una politica monetaria di un
intero stato di un insieme di stati
perché ad oggi non sappiamo che siamo un
unione europea alla banca centrale e la
bce quindi un attimino questa cosa non
può essere moneta quindi la prima sfida
concettuale creduto affrontare è di cosa
cavolo
stiamo parlando moneta valuta estera
comodati titolo diritto al baratto mezzo
di pagamento ipotizzate di tutte sono
addirittura arrivato a fare un
ragionamento dicendo ma insomma è vero
che viene utilizzata come moneta perché
qualcuno è disposto ad accettarla in
pagamento rispetto a un credito che
vanta un credito che poi prova a
diventare per aver fatto un servizio un
credo che può vantare per aver ceduto un
bene per qualsiasi motivo per qualcuno
disposto ad accettarla ma quali sono gli
esempi storici di metodi alternativi di
pagamento diversi rispetto alla moneta e
ne abbiamo tanti brutto pensare ma nei
campi di concentramento era valuta
corrente c'era moneta che veniva
normalmente utilizzata che cosa le
sigarette quelle hanno assunto un'altra
funzione rispetto quello che
era il loro scopo principale bene quindi
bitcoin potrebbe essere un bene
esattamente tanto quanto le sigarette
però c'è un piccolo problema concettuale
la sigaretta se non la vendo ho voglia
di fumare me ne 1 aprendo la cella me la
fumo bitcoin se non lo spendo seno l'uso
in pagamento cosa ci posso fare questo
ragionamento che mi sono fatto io nelle
mie stanzette nel mio ufficio da
commercialista cattivo il caldo mentre
sudavo per capire cosa doveva fare
questo povero tapino con i redditi che
lui sperava di formare con i bitcoin poi
in quel momento in come ne parlò fu il
caso del primo grosso per un grosso
fallimento di un exchange lui aveva
tutti quei bitcoin su quelle exchange
quelli xchange è fallito quindi una
realizzata nessun reddito
ho studiato tanto per nulla ma questo mi
capita spesso che quindi in quel caso
cioè della nota positiva a vantaggio del
mio amico che non gli ha dato tasse da
pagare
quindi ogni tanto ci riesce anche di
essere non dico buoni ma quantomeno
sterili improduttivi di effetti negativi
comunque fatto sta che questo tipo di
domanda non me la sono posta io perché
il mondo è enorme e soprattutto un mondo
come questo è liquido
cioè è l'evoluzione di bitcoin ha messo
in collegamento e peer to peer ha messo
in collegamento qualsiasi utente con
qualsiasi altro utente in tutto il mondo
per cui la stessa domanda che lui ha
fatto a me tanta altra gente la stava
facendo a tanti altri commercialisti in
giro per il mondo
fino a quando il signor at least va
dalla sua amministrazione finanziaria e
dice addirittura io voglio creare un
exchange cioè voglio creare un sito
presso il quale la gente viene mida
della moneta avente corso legale quindi
la moneta fiat e io in cambio i do the
bitcoin oppure il contrario ad ebi coin
belli vuole rivendere i li ridò indietro
la moneta avente corso legale questa
operazione non è nient'altro che un
operazione l'intermediazione
l'intermediazione ovviamente lo sapete
quando vai a comprare moneta
di un'altra valuta la paghi qualcosina
in più quando la vendite la pagano
qualcosa di meno per questo perché il
margine di questo tipo di attività si
tiene da quello che ha detto il margine
di intermediazione della moneta bene
questo signore va dalla sua
amministrazione finanziaria dice prima
di tutto io voglio fare questa
operazione ma risolviamo il primo
problema libico e sono soggette diva e
poi secondo problema immagine che io
ottengo in questo modo è una prestazione
di servizi o una prestazione di servizi
che può essere considerata inerente a o
similare una prestazione di cambio di
valute a 20 corso legale perché quel
tipo di prestazione non è una domanda
fatta a caso scontava già l'esenzione
dal pagamento dell'iva
fatto sta che l'amministrazione
finanziaria il primo grado la nostra da
equivalente della sorta di commissione
tributaria preventiva perché paesi
evoluti si possono chiedere dei giudizi
preventivi qui in italia è poco
possibile attuare uno strumento e già
sono tramite il meccanismo degli
interpelli ma che poi vedremo dopo
non sono molto efficaci comunque si
trova una risposta assolutamente
positiva si va e tranquillo fa eppure la
tua attività e bitcoin secondo noi sono
un strumento di pagamento tanto quanto
la valuta per cui come la valuta non c'è
l'applicazione dell'iva di sconti di
esenzioni va talmente presente che
questo fatto della pendenza della
questione se pagare o meno l'iva sui
bitcoin voleva dire che se ci fosse
stata una pronuncia di sì
iva da pagare sui bitcoin l'intero
sistema europeo l'intero sistema iva
perché l'iva è un'imposta che si applica
armonizzata su tutto il territorio della
comunità europea avrebbe comportato che
in europa non si sarebbe sviluppata
mezza attività avente ad oggetto blog
c'è il bitcoin scritto valute quindi
quello che vi sto raccontando mi sembra
una cosa che fuori dal mondo troppo
tecnica ma non è tecnica perché la
ricaduta è immediata la ricaduta è
perdere quelle occasioni che ci hanno
detto che ci proietteranno nel futuro
qui in italia abbiamo tra le migliori
teste tra i migliori sviluppatori nel
mondo blow chain e critto valute
se il nostro legislatore non comprende
questo tipo di passaggi e non crea non
dico un terreno che deve agevolare
questo tipo attività rispetto alle altre
ma non deve ostacolarle e soprattutto di
un mondo così tanto liquido come un caso
che vi ho appena raccontato cioè che
dall'altra parte dell'europa un soggetto
si è trovato a fare la stessa domanda
alla propria agenzia delle entrate può
trovarsi una risposta positiva in italia
non faremo niente e il nostro soggetto
di un mondo così liquido non ci mette
niente spostare il proprio computer e la
propria testa perché quella con cui
produce un protocollo informatico in un
altro paese dove questo è possibile
comunque il nostro social si sente di
una prima volta si la seconda volta è
l'agenzia delle entrate che si appella
la stessa agenzia ed entra 13 svedese
sempre diceva non è possibile
secondo noi no deve pagarci sopra ne va
perché perché lo stato ha sempre fame ed
iva e tenete presente che l'iva è né una
delle imposte più subdole che ci sia
perché dov'è che colpisce l'iva colpisce
il consumo voi per consumare cosa
utilizzate gli euro che avete in tasca
gli euro che avete in tasca sono gli
euro che avete guadagnato sul quale
avete già pagato le tasse
quindi è la forma più subdola di doppia
imposizione che esista comunque il
nostro soggetto si trova in questa
situazione tanto vero che questa causa
arriva fino alla corte di giustizia
europea perché è importante la corte di
giustizia europea perché la corte di
giustizia europea
andando a pronunciarsi su una materia
come l'iva la pronuncia che produce
quindi il giudizio che esprime è
vincolante per tutti i paesi della
comunità europea e lì in quel momento
c'è stato lo stallo perché esse della
corte di giustizia dice sì si applica
l'iva questo mondo è finito e si parlava
del 2014 poi sentenza pubblicata nel
se avesse detto no non è soggetto ad iva
quindi prevediamo la stessa esenzione
per le valute estere possiamo pensare di
aver messo uno sviluppo armonico
orbene questa sentenza fa molto di più
perché indaga in maniera
molto puntuale e soprattutto ci se vi
invito a leggere interessati alla
questione le la relazione
accompagnatoria dell'avvocato generale
della corte di giustizia europea alla
causa c 264 del 2014
perché in quella stessa causa si fanno
quei passaggi melodici mentali che vi
dicevo prima delle sigarette dell'oro
utilizzato come mezzo di pagamento cioè
di questi che però sono beni che
esauriscono la loro capacità anche in
altre funzioni qual è la singolarità di
bitcoin che può essere utilizzato solo
unicamente come mezzo di pagamento
quindi si fa una lunga analisi nella
quale la conclusione definitiva è che
può essere non è una valuta non è una
valuta vere corso legale perché nessuno
non c'è nessuna autorità centrale che la
garantisca non è equiparabile assegni o
altri effetti cambiari o altri effetti
al portatore perché quelli esprimono un
valore facciale di cose di una valle
valute avente corso legale mentre
l'unità di conta è lo stesso bitcoin
quindi non ha le caratteristiche per
essere alla valuta corrente però una
caratteristica funda fondamentale della
prima funzione della moneta e cioè
quella di essere un mezzo di pagamento e
quindi bitcoin è una categoria a sé di
mezzo di pagamento perché vi dico che è
importante la definizione perché la
categoria giuridica in cui diamo
identificarlo in cui la corte di
giustizia è stata molto precisa e
puntuale
ovviamente in questo mondo dinamico si
ripropone anche come caso su cui si deve
pronunciare la nostra agenzia delle
entrate 2016 e senza entrate si trova a
doversi pronunciare su cosa sia bikaner
riprende la sentenza della corte di
giustizia e per noi operatori e per noi
studiosi del diritto diciamo a
illuminante perché sembra averlo capito
e poi come se due righe prima avesse
detto abbiamo capito quella sentenza
corte giustizia che ci dice che non sono
volute essere tre righe dopo ci dice
applicate tutta la normativa delle
imposte dirette e
indirette e relativa alle valute estere
questo sembra non avere delle ricadute
particolari ma anche una pronuncia di
questo tipo io vi parlo solo di
un'azienda che vuole sviluppare un
commercio nel quale accetta anche
bitcoin oppure di un miner che vuole
produrre bitcoin che ancora meglio se io
miner produco bitcoin produco dei beni
come se producessi questi tele comandini
io una volta che io prodotti cielo il
magazzino quando li vendo realizzò un
ricavo se io invece vado dire che quello
che io produco e valuta nel momento
stesso in cui questo compare magicamente
nella mia disponibilità nelle mie mani
quindi la produzione è stata fatta
quello per me è immediatamente un ricavo
farlo su un bene che è soggetto a una
valutazione di un mercato secondario e
valutazione che oggi è estremamente
variabile cosa mi comporta che caso 2017
se avesse valutato la mia produzione di
dieci di coin avrei detto portare a
tassazione 165 mila euro di ricavi
pagare le tasse a giugno 2018 in quel
caso di quelli con ce l'avevo ancora in
mano non gli avevo venduti ha voluto
calcolare una tassazione che nel nostro
paese nel circa il 50 60 per cento del
fatturato del dell'utile effettivamente
prodotto pari tradotti in euro i 165
mila euro quindi in 50 per cento sugli
80 e passa mila euro utilizzando quei
dieci picco anche l'hanno ancora venduto
ma allo stato non accetta i 5 b con cioè
il 50 per cento per pagare le tasse ne
avrebbe chiesto l'euro orbene dal 31 12
2000 e 17 a giugno 2018 b oltre che
dimezzato il proprio valore
quindi se io considero quella valuta
avente corso legale vuol dire che al 31
12 mi fa identificare i 360 e passa mila
euro al 30 06 mi chiedi la tassazione
del 50 per cento ma io ancora 10 bitcoin
dico va bene andrò a liquidare 5 b con e
pagherà tra 7 no perché quel valore
oscilla perché quella è oggetto di un
la valutazione continua del mercato e
vendendoli non avrei neanche ricavato il
quantitativo monetario di euro per
andare assolvere il debito d'imposta per
cui una pronuncia di quel tipo ha delle
ricadute grosse ricadute grosse quali
sono che un qualsiasi soggetto che
dovrebbe imprendere ovviamente non
guarderà questo paese come favorevole
all'introduzione di questo tipo di
tecnologia
purtroppo stessa linea la seguono anche
nell'intervallo numero 956 bara 39 del
2018 d'opera della lombardia cioè
direzione regionale lombardia qui
vivicità un'altra sentenza della corte
di cassazione sezioni unite che è
fondamentale perché quella sentenza ci
dice che visto che queste due pronunce
delle agenzie delle entrate per quanto
loro le abbiano deciso di pubblicare per
orientare il mercato ei contribuenti
quella sentenza ci dice che quelle due
pezzi sono carta straccia non ha nessun
valore giuridico e questa è l'unica
fortuna che ci ha portato fino qua a
riuscire da mantenere delle imprese e
dei soggetti che vogliono intraprendere
in questo tipo di attività ovviamente
come dicevo prima si va avanti e andare
avanti in questo tipo di mondo vuol dire
che ogni sei mesi la blow chain di
bitcoin ha visto poi nascere tante
sorelle e tante sorelle con delle
possibilità di applicazioni enormemente
diverse e tanti business correlati tanto
che l'intervento del legislatore ha
dovuto orientarsi anche su altri aspetti
non solo quelli della tassazione
un altro aspetto fondamentale che ha
dovuto analizzare il nostro legislatore
è quello relativo alla normativa
antiriciclaggio e contro finanziamento
il terrorismo
cioè l'anti ma nei land ring questo è un
obiettivo fondamentale del legislatore
cioè guardare i flussi finanziari e che
tali flussi non vadano a fomentare
mercati illeciti o addirittura
finanziare il terrorismo o addirittura
costituire motivo di riciclaggio qual è
il nuovo paradigma che introduce bitcoin
noi sappiamo che col denaro contante le
transazioni sono totalmente ignote se
c'è una transazione tra due soggetti
quali in platea e nessuno li vede che si
scambiano denaro contante noi non possa
sapere chi sono e non possa sapere
quanto denaro si sono scambiati nel
sistema invece finanziario quello bank
noto a noi bancario sostanzialmente la
transazione è nota e i soggetti che
pongono in essere questa transazione
sono noti sono noti che sono la notte
chi noi riteniamo come fiduciario del di
questo tipo di dati informazioni ed è
l'istituto bancario di chi di ogni parte
coinvolta nella transazione
in più vi possono accedere anche le
autorità e purtroppo vi possono accedere
anche tanti soggetti che magari possono
essere anche malintenzionati sfruttare
quel tipo di informazione contro di voi
qual è la vera rivoluzione di bitcoin la
rivoluzione di bitcoin è che la
transazione essendo scritto su un blocco
che comunque può andare a controllare
una transazione pubblica una transazione
pubblica dove gli utenti sono tra
virgolette ignoti perché l'indirizzo
pubblico mio che mando soldi a lui e il
suo indirizzo pubblico che li riceve
saranno sempre visibili sulla blow cene
e saranno sempre noti a chiunque però
come indirizzi pubblici per associare
quegli indirizzi pubblici a me oa lui
l'unica cosa che possiamo fare è andare
a scoprire qual è la chiave privata che
può muovere quell'indirizzo pubblico
quindi con questo per dirvi con una
buona attività forense se io in un modo
o nell'altro riesco a collegare un
indirizzo pubblico a un soggetto e
faccio tutte le transazioni partendo dal
mio computer un buon investigatore
forense che si mette libro attaccato al
suo computer da collegare il mio
indirizzo ip a quell'indirizzo pubblico
e il tempo abbastanza breve verrà
collegato io a quell'indirizzo pubblico
per cui anche quando vi dicono che la
moneta utilizzata per finanziare il
terrorismo per fare atti illeciti non
credeteci perché vi stanno facendo il
lavaggio del cervello gli articoli del
90 al 94 al 2000 che parlavano di
internet erano il posto che viene
utilizzato per realizzare attività
criminali satanisti il regno di
satanisti pedofili su internet che viene
spacciata la droga e si possono comprare
le armi questi erano i titoli che
campeggiavano sui media in quegli anni
oggi internet fa parte di tutti tutta la
nostra vita ma stavo per dirvi da quando
andiamo a dormire quando ci dal cielo
quando ci svegliamo con andiamo a
dormire non è così perché ormai abbiamo
anche le nostre case che tramite di
dispositivi che comprano per pochi euro
sono sempre collegate sono sempre
connesse internet ormai è parte della
nostra quotidianità
questo succederà anche con veloce né
bitcoin non preoccupatevi succederà
l'unica cosa che noi possiamo fare è
sbagliare a recepire questo tipo di
innovazione e trovarsi un legislatore
che non la comprende e non comprendendo
la lo stage a tipo quello che sta
succedendo in italia e che si vuole fare
una parificazione con le valute estere e
questa è la cosa più sbagliata che ci
sia perché la quinta direttiva cioè
quella di stampo europeo nella
definizione di cosa sono le volute
virtuali ci dice chiaramente che non
possiedano lo status giuridico di voluta
moneta nella proposta di recepimento
italiana il nostro legislatore interno
per recepire una direttiva da cui per
visto che faccia parte della comunità
europea abbia firmato i trattati per cui
quelle direttivi toria dovremmo
prenderli esattamente come quella che
era la traduzione della lingua inglese
della normativa madre per cui non
dovremmo cambiare quasi una virgola la
proposta di introduzione alla normativa
interna cioè quella italiana
cancella quella frase non possedere
status giuridico di voluto moneta perché
perché lui quelli dell'ufficio di fianco
sono quelli dell'agenzia delle entrate
della banca d'italia netto ma fino
all'altro giorno abbia detto che valuta
estera
non possiamo che fare le figuracce così
ma questa figuraccia vorrebbe dire che
questo tipo di normativa la normativa
anti money laundering che è l'anti
riciclaggio italiano cioè quello per cui
la banca negli ultimi 45 anni mi ha
fatto firmare una montagna così di carte
ogni volta che andate al notaio vi
chiede i soldi per fare quel tipo
operazione dove provengono quella
normativa che è estremamente pervasiva
nei vostri componi confronti che però
non dovete compilare con date al
panettiere lo pagate non dovete
compilare quando andate da un qualsiasi
altro soggetto a comprare un treno di
gomme per la macchina quello non lo
dovete fare bene sappiate che secondo
quella riga tirata lì sopra se il vostro
gommista decide se accettare bitcoin voi
dovreste compilare tutta la normativa
che complete per la banca se il vostro
panettiere di accettare di vedere se
comprare quella roba secondo voi si può
diffondere la tecnologia di questo tipo
dove un legislatore obbliga un
panettiere fare fare l'anti anni ma
scusate la ml quindi la schedatura
antiriciclaggio al panettiere per tutti
i suoi clienti che volessero pagarlo con
bitcoin si diffonda la tecnologia di
cosa tipo di un posto del genere
no quindi quello che noi dobbiamo fare è
diffondere questo tipo di coscienza
dico e non sono il male non hanno mai
fatto nessuno male a nessuno e dobbiamo
capire una cosa fondamentale che ve l'ho
scritta di sopra non è possibile
arginare l'acqua mani nude
così come è possibile fermare
normativamente ed evoluzione della
tecnologia il diritto in questo caso
insegue la tecnica perché la tecnica in
continua evoluzione
cosa deve fare coscientemente il diritto
l'unica cosa che può fare è dare degli
argini
qui c'è la legalità
se vai oltre questo argine se oltre la
legalità perché se ragionassi in questa
maniera positiva vorrebbe dire che se un
martello viene utilizzato per commettere
un omicidio io dietro tutti i martelli
se un picco inutilizzato per comprare
della droga
io non posso vietare tutti i bitcoin
quindi
perché voglio dire oggi abbiamo vissuto
questo momento così di approfondimento
di qualche di questo nuovo paradigma di
questa nuova rivoluzione informatica
questo è l'unico modo per tentare di
fare cultura di diffondere sapere perché
il giorno che il legislatore ci verrà a
imporre che il panettiere ci faccia la
schedatura inter riciclaggio si vuole
accettare bitcoin non gli diremo no caro
legislatore così non si può andare
avanti
[Applauso]
[Musica]